the other day
i'm ordering
i guess what i want to talk about is
autism
you know i'm ordering some cottage
cheese at a uh breakfast place i'm
ordering some cottage cheese
and it's it you know it's a rare choice
it is what it is i ordered it
the guy goes uh
i don't know if we have cottage cheese
but let me see
what i can do for you
that's nice that's a sweet guy
so i wait he brings over a bowl he
brings over a bowl
and it's like
three or four pieces of cheese cut up in
a little bitty
and shapes kind of just
and he just kind of stacked them all in
a little bowl
and i i just i mean this [ __ ] just i'm
grateful you know i didn't want that's
not how i didn't want things like that
but the guy made an effort
but i think what we're starting to see
more and more is autism
you know we're starting to see it more
as a uh
it's a positive in this and because
here's what it is
a lot of big business owners now
you know uh jeff bezos
um elon musk
they have autism
you know nobody wants to flat out say it
but if you're part computer part person
that's always what autism was autism was
that you know
you know was danny calculator it was
that dude who you would start talking
you would reach out to shake his hand
and he would kind of shake he would
shake your hand with his eyes you know
he would like kind of just look look at
you look down look up look down look up
like he was you know he's part computer
it's built into him
and those are people that are starting
to rule the world because the world is
becoming more man and more computer
it's mur you know we're emerging it's
that man you know it's that man pewter
you know
that compumen you know it's that um
it's that middle ground
you'll put a uh
you'll put your hand in a woman's pants
and she'll have a damn uh you know a
quarter of a keyboard down there
you know and you'll just start typing in
p you know c-l-i-t or you know
labia or whatever however you spell it
you know you don't even you're not even
really touching the genitals anymore
you're just typing in the words of it
you know uh uh uh you're just
u-h-h-u-h-h-u-h-h
until they you know
i'm just saying we're starting to we're
seeing the merging of people
and that's what you know it's just and
those are people that are going to rule
the world because it's
it's just we're becoming more of both
we're becoming more computerized
automated atm
blender
you know you just
so just being a human is not
it's good but it's old-fashioned
the these these people that are doing it
all now are people that can see both
worlds
at once
and sometimes you get the jeff bezos
sometimes you get the um
sometimes you get the elon musk
and sometimes uh you get patrick you get
the dude who brought me
who cut up four pieces of cheese into a
bowl
you know it's kind it's a light autism
it's not helping anybody really but
you know it it helps that you know it's
it it's it works at a diner a little bit
i guess
we're emerging i wonder are we becoming
more robots
you know you see these people that have
the
that have you know
half a calculator behind their eyes and
and uh
and they're more
uh operating system than they are heart
and you want you're like you know you
start to wonder are they
the next evolution
am i just out here living in the stone
age
with my feelings
when three generations from now it'll be
you know it'll all you know
they'll have our feelings almost
well have been taken over by some type
of
or crossbred with a gigabyte and
and uh
and you'll press a button on your hip
and you'll smile
you know it i just i don't i don't know
what the future is going to be like i
don't know
but i believe that autism is that gray
area where we're starting to see maybe
because it used to be somebody at all
telling me like damn ricky's [ __ ] up
you know
oh damn ricky's over there licking that
snake
ricky's licking snakes
but now
you're like damn
you know
ricky's licking snakes
and uh
and he's running a damn app
you know he owns four apps so you're
like well he's really
he's doing well you know
he started a damn petco on his phone
all but you know where he started
selling leather goods because he learned
of
you know
he just tasted that texture for so long
on the back of that rattler and next
thing you know
he's out here vending damn purses you
know fendi purses or something
you know uh
you know he's out here you know making
milk snake uh
um
you know he's out here making milk snake
sand skin sandals
for deaf children or whatever and he's
you know he won an uh academy award or
whatever
and he's got autism i'm just saying i
don't know i don't know anything
and i never have so
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you